[Music]
what's going on here
poppy mommy's here can we keep him my
neighbor's dog had a little they're
looking for people to adopt
i love him i wish he had tiny puppy
shoes
i would totally shine his little shoes
for free oh i do say the cutest stuff
look i love a good dog as much as the
next guy but this building doesn't allow
animals
andy take him outside and shoot him no
just keep him outside oh come on ron
i'm just a little puppy i ain't done
nothing wrong
i'm just a puppy i like your mustache
i wish i could have one but i can't
cause i'm just a little bubbly
okay take him out and shoot him
attention everyone
say goodbye to the jake peralta you know
and love
where today is the day i forever change
ooh
are you finally growing a mustache no
you know i can't do that and it's cruel
of you to keep bringing it up
this envelope contains the inheritance
my uncle left me he died a year ago he
was so rich
he had a whole room in his house just to
eat him you mean like a dining room
yeah but in manhattan oh dang now just
because i'm definitely rich now doesn't
mean i'm gonna forget my roots you all
get something so fire away
jake your friendship is gift enough for
me friendship is crap i want a ducati
monster 8 21.
all right rosa gets a motorcycle oh cool
i want a fast sports car
come on you could be honest i want old
expensive books i'll send you a list
there you go now let's find out what i'm
worth
uh i'm too nervous to open it sarge you
do it okay
it's stock one million shares oh my god
i love blockbuster video stuff oh what
is that bad i still have a blockbuster
card
what happened to blockbuster so
who broke it i'm not mad
i just want to know
i did i no no you didn't tom
don't look at me look at ben what
i didn't break it huh that's weird how'd
you even know it's broken
because it's sitting right in front of
us and it's broken
suspicious no it's not if it matters
probably not but
april was the last one to use liar i
don't even drink that crap oh really
then what were you doing by the coffee
cart earlier use the wooden stirrers to
push back my cuticles everyone knows
that
jerry okay let's not fight i broke it
let me pay for it run no
who broke it
ron don has been awfully quiet really
yeah really
i broke it it burned my hand so i
punched it
i predict 10 minutes from now they'll be
at each other's throats with war paint
on their faces and a pig head on a stick
it was getting a little chummy around
here sorry sorry
sorry i just had to grab my wall
[Music]
gentlemen
fine i was trying something and it
didn't work okay
here's the situation your parents went
away on a week's vacation
they left the keys to the brand new
porsche but they mine
well of course not i'll just take it for
a little spin
and maybe show it off to a couple of
friends
i'll just cruise around the neighborhood
well maybe i shouldn't yeah of course i
should
pay attention here's the thick of the
plot i pulled up to the corner at the
end of my block that's when i saw this
beautiful girly girl walking i picked up
my car
phone to perpetrate like i was talking
the sunroof was open the music was high
and that girl's hand was steadily moving
up
my thigh she had opened up three buttons
on her shirt so far i guess that's why i
didn't notice that police car
i can't believe it i made a mistake my
parents are the same no matter time nor
place
so to all your kids all across the land
no need to argue parents just don't
understand
all right thank you thank you
just a little something i know so what's
up uh someone is on fire and ram's at
park they need you to get down there
right away
oh my god come here come here
you gotta see this i'm about to give
captain holt his gift
oh did he lift his no gift policy no he
didn't
but i figured out a way to buy him
something and trick him into accepting
it
you are bad i know right oh wait you're
making fun of me
well i don't care he would never open a
gift right but
what if his gift didn't look like a gift
he would open it
exactly i left it in a cardboard box on
his desk
there's no card just the words open now
which i wrote with my wrong hand so he
wouldn't recognize my handwriting
captain santiago peralta sir so just to
recap you left an unmarked package on a
police captain's desk on a random monday
with a suspicious message written on
that looked like it was scrawled by a
crazy person bomb there's a bomb
everyone out let's go this is not a
drill let's go
great gift babe i am submitting this
a brief history of everything that has
ever happened
since pawnee was founded not like you
get extra credit for this but i did type
it from memory and for the first time
ever compiled it includes
a complete list of every official town
slogan we've ever had oh my god that was
late i know can you believe it crazy
isn't it pawnee the paris of america
pawnee the akron of southwest indiana
pawnee welcome german soldiers
after the nazis took france our mayor
kind of panicked pawnee the factory fire
capital of america
pawnee welcome vietnamese soldiers
pawnee engage with zorp
for a brief time in the 70s our town was
taken over by a cult
pawnee zorp is dead long live zorp
pawnee it's safe to be here now
pawnee birthplace of julia roberts that
was a lie she sued and so we had to
change it
pawnee home of the world famous julia
roberts lawsuit
pawnee welcome taliban soldiers and
finally our current slogan
pawnee first in friendship fourth in
obesity
hey there boyle how was your weekend
well actually i got a little sick
oh really i'm sorry to hear that man
yeah bullets over broadway was on tv i
came down with a big old diane
weast infection
like yeast mr haverford on the morning
of your crash were you alone in your car
yes your honor this was an accident
plain and simple i don't want to put
words in your mouth but
case dismissed and you were texting at
the time correct how dare you sir
i was tweeting please read exhibit c the
transcript of your twitter page leading
up to and immediately following your
crash
9 15. four green lights in a row hashtag
blessed
917 drive faster blue civic damn
soccer moms 918. gotta pass this lady on
the edge
that's when i hit the fire hydrant sorry
allegedly
get the fire hydrant 920 just hit a fire
hydrant but i survived
hashtag unbreakable what's mr glass up
to these days
why no sequel prosecution restauranter
mr haverford do you have a problem
keeping your eyes on the road and off
your electronic devices
i'm gonna tailor a punishment to fit the
crime
one week without screens no phone
tablets computers television
anything no please send me to jail any
slip-ups and that week becomes a month
turn in your phone please fine one last
tweet bailiff
wow someone had a good time in paris oh
kevin and i shared a perfect week
together i feel like i'm floating on a
gua song i wonder why people don't just
break into song more often
i've been asking you for months if i
could answer the phone like
give it a whirl girl
guys he's rhyming he's telling gina to
sing
captain holt is on a vacation high he
will say yes to anything right now
i would like a police source and i'd
like terry to be riding it almost
constantly
i'd like an hr person to remind everyone
about workplace boundaries
the japanese make toilet seats which
squirt a heated jet of water
right up your i'm gonna stop you right
there bud what we need in here
is an armored personnel carrier a tank
two tanks i want a tank two
great so everyone gets a tank just
remember we can't ruin captain holt's
vacation high so no one say anything
that'll upset him oh no what are those
morons doing in there well maybe it's
not that bad maybe they didn't upset him
what did you do what'd you say
nothing we just said welcome back and
laughed with him about all the weight he
gained in france
why is everyone just standing around get
back to work
so long tank tank i gained three pounds
in paris
three pounds
you